c'est un bâtiment de six étages quelque
part dans l'île oui bonjour monsieur
c'est pour le reportage l'adresse du
centre d'hébergement est gardée secrète
pour éviter que les conjoints violents
puissent retrouver leurs compagnes on
n'entre pas ici sans sans montrer patte
blanche en difficulté c'est la raison
pour laquelle on est prudent à bien
contrôler les entrées sorties de
l'établissement
le centre accueille des femmes victimes
de violences et leurs enfants mais
également toute personne nécessitant un
hébergement pour quelques jours ou
quelques semaines ce sont souvent des
sdf et plus généralement toute personne
en détresse sociale
christine elle est arrivée il ya deux
semaines avec ses deux filles son petit
garçon
refi on a mis à sa disposition ce petit
appartement ici c'est là où j'adore il
ya un petit coin de lavabo en fait je me
se retrouver ici parce que à la maison
avec mon mari c'était assez violent ou
cas c'est tout menacé devant les enfants
menaces de mort
comment s'est passée la décision est à
un point où où les enfants sont là en
train de pleurer peur que il agit c'est
là qu'on se dit bah c'est pas une vie
pour les enfants
pour contrer cette violence et ou
comment on comprend ça la violence des
hommes
ben je crois pas le fait qu'on ordinance
la tête est bloquée comme on dit en
créole
et puis bon ben on commence à se dire
que c'est notre foi à coup une femme
peut dire ça c'est mon choix ben
on va dire que c'est elle qui fait pas
son rôle comme il faut rôle de femme au
final qu on en parlais à des amis on
voit que c'est peut-être pas nous
problème
vous avez ressenti en arrivant ici la
tristesse franchement c'est dur c'est
dire la jeune femme très amaigrie que
réconforte deux autres pensionnaires à
l'extérieur du centre d'hébergement elle
est arrivée il ya quelques jours avec
ses deux garçons mais son ex-conjoint
n'arrête pas de la harceler au téléphone
depuis trois jours elle n'arrive plus à
manger
alors ce matin un éducateur l'emmène à
l'hôpital
alten est sonné et là patatrac du nord
ah tiens plus
montrer ces passerelles était belle
comme un tic kurmann quoi je veux dire
quand elle m'a raconté comment elle est
partie elle a dû attendre que les led
partent au boulot
séparés
m
était tellement dans une emprise pouvait
pas partir au début et si c'est oui
où elle est souvent les hommes ils
essaient de venir ici
un monsieur qui passe du scooter avec sa
machette
et de tuer
deux personnes qui font
[Musique]
allez bon jour pour sam stas temps oui
sandra a 27 ans et quatre enfants
savannah champ
vivement que rien c'est bon sens trahi
ses enfants sont arrivés il ya un peu
plus d'un mois le conjoint violent à
l'interdiction de les approcher
je suis venu c'est par rapport au bpa de
maison pour me taper bas prix de monaco
mais je ne verrais ça t1 ne sera qu'une
bonne mis au monde à la télé mais je
comment pas dispo est un tout
ap le lendemain matin et annie devant
mon portail à ce qui pourrait tout à
fait être mon pote mais a appelé matière
téléphone à la loi est la loi la disco
mais vaut mieux une savonnette ou de
foyers et après c'est la police qui
connaissent en fait ne veut pas dire que
nous l'important pour eux que nikon ou
pas oui parce que c'est les connaît un
problème les enfants ce qui comprend
qu'on savait qu'on y arriverait site web
manage comme un papa et méchant pas ta
maman papa trappe couteau manenti pas
bien pour mes débuts par rapport qu'on
ne la ratez rien n'arrive
le truc me mène une bataille aubry
on voit descendre la piste instant à au
bureau on y va
c'est des savates des chaussures des
gamins mathieu l'éducateur spécialisé
emmène la petite bande dans son bureau
depuis l'arrivée de sandra au centre
d'hébergement ils l'accompagnent dans
toutes ses démarches à savoir sandra va
pouvoir bénéficier d'un avocat lors du
procès de son conjoint violent prévu
dans quinze jours il faut aussi
s'occuper de l'école des enfants
oui bonjour ce que je prends la
directrice ou le directeur s'il vous
plaît ce serait pour une demande de
radiation s'il vous plaît pour que les
enfants puissent être inscrit dans une
nouvelle école il faut d'abord les
radiers de l'ancienne et comme souvent
le père s'y opposent parce que du coup
on se retrouve un peu bloqué pour la
scolarisation des enfants
l'école c'est ça l'école c'est ok c'est
bon on attend 10 la radiation
j'ai pas le droit
dans quelques jours le problème réglé et
puis ce sera retour à l'école
quelle joie puis on s'occupera de
chercher un logement pour sandra et ses
enfants
car c'est l'objectif des séjours au
centre d'hébergement construire un
projet et permettre aux femmes de
repartir comme jessica qui quitte le
foyer cet après-midi après y avoir passé
plus de trois mois
comme sandra comme christine c'est pour
elle une nouvelle vie qui commence
oui
oui je
tél ça va prendre du temps mais je pense
que vous sauvez ce père acheteurs ont
fait mon kit on kiffe
une nouvelle maison nouvelles places
avec consentement
en sécurité est en sécurité c'est vrai
que c'est pas évident de quitter son
foyer
ses habitudes
après je pense que c'est un moment à
passer après peut-être un bel avenir à
goutte et surtout plaisant